this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks a lot bill for this very nice and
kind introduction
it's a really a pleasure to be here and
also to have the opportunity to talk
twice to to the audience here and I see
some places that you'll see both
presentations and they are quite
different although I have to apologize
for all the horticulturist here in the
audience I'm a molecular biologist and I
will do my best to hook up the things we
do to physiologically physiological
aspects morphological aspects but there
will be quite some molecular biology in
it so I hope you can follow it or that
you came afterwards catch up again when
we go back to a slightly different topic
so yeah flowering time research in tulip
and as bill nicely indicated the Dutch
Growers Association Koenig Luca all
humming and for anything for broomball
and go through they are financing a lot
and nowadays also steamer flori
it's financing part of my research so I
think this you're all aware of the
Netherlands is their country of of
tulips although they do not originate
from Holland they come from from Turkey
Iran that's the region where originally
tulip is growing and and native from but
already from from many years tubes are
very popular in the Netherlands and in
the 16th century tulips were even used
as a way of currency so they had a very
high value and people paid with tulip
bulbs their bills or that completely
collapsed and it was also the very first
financial disaster I think on the on the
stock market but then still tulips are
important products for the Netherlands
and the coke and off that is our tulip
and and Boo Boo's plant ornamental
garden it's only open for you one or two
months a year but it's getting more
visitors than for example the Q
Botanical Gardens in the UK which are
very popular so in that respect we are
really a tulip country well then you
would maybe also think there's a lot of
research on going into your lip and well
unfortunately in the past was a lot of
physiological research but nowadays that
really drops and we are very happy that
Bo is still a very active in that but if
you see in the Midlands it's quite
disappointing the amount of efforts that
are put into fundamental and applied
research in boobs
research so what I will do today is I
will give you a very short outline how I
came in forced into the research and
then I will talk about different aspects
of flower induction by spring
temperatures program temperature is an
important aspect dormancy control in
tulip by winter cold then shortly apart
on vegetative reproduction and very sure
what we hope to do in the near future so
first a little bit of history at 2010
this Royal Botanical Society had is and
100 years anniversary and then they say
to the Dutch a government of Agriculture
and economical affairs we would like to
get a kind of present for our birthday
and they said well there's hardly any
research ongoing we would like to
install a professor especially on booze
pond research for one day in a week and
then that professor can set up a small
team if two PhDs and they got that money
and then it was an it took quite long to
set it all up and in 2012 you could
apply for that position and build made
the very nice joke this morning I said
well I had not worked before with tulips
and the title of it was physiology of
flower bulbs of this special tier I was
not a physiologist molecular biologist
so billed directly said if you want
somebody that has no knowledge on tulips
not on physiology you were the guide the
job and they selected me somehow so and
the reason for that is that has to do
with the topics they selected the
research topic because at the start of
this special chair is that there are two
topics we would like to work on and it's
flowering time control so one PhD
student studying that topic and the
second one the regulation of vegetative
propagation in tulip and also they said
well preferably we would like you to
work on Chile but not on other booba
species with a really focused research
program and my background is especially
in flowering time research and that's
why they said well maybe you are the
correct candidate to do this research
and also to get somebody who has a
complete different view on yeah what
what should maybe be done and what we
can learn from from Chile research
so that's how it started so as I
indicated already I'm not a physiologist
so it will be more molecular biology or
flower boobs sorry for that but that's
just because that was my experience and
it was also the approach we followed
so at any question is how to start as I
indicated my knowledge team in Toulouse
was not that big I'm a molecular
biologist so and up to them mainly
physiological research was done food
quality physiological research but there
was a clear-cut lack on basic
information like there is no genome
sequence of tulip there are hardly any
papers out with a molecular approach
proteomics transcriptomics it was really
nothing when we started to work on Julie
so yeah one thing you can think they
know let's go and sequence the genome
but that's quite challenging because
tulip is in comparison to Arabic DOCSIS
it's huge its genome is even much bigger
than our own genome 25 Giga base pairs
and I directly said well that is
something I'm not going to do but what
then and then we said well maybe it's
more interesting to look to the active
part of the of the genome as a start and
start using transcriptomics and that's
what we did we initially said well let's
set up a kind of basic platform for what
people can also start using and what we
did is we selected at three different
time points during the growth cycle of
an adult's julep we selected material so
January March and made in a grow season
and then we took five tissue scales
axillary buds leave stem and flower from
one cultivar dynasty and we said let's
do an RNAi cheek on that so there they
get secret information available well
that's what we did at that moment we
also decided to do a similar approach
for Lily and I will show later on why we
were also interested in Lily so what we
did in is we we did the sequencing but
then we said well to make it available
for the for the scientific community it
would also be nice if somehow there is a
kind of of tier the ARB adopts this
information resource for what your lips
is by far not like that but at least
that people can and do simple searches
like a blast search to find there
sequences so at that moment I asked my
by intuition to set up a website and
it's still online
if one of you wants to use it and you
get a an error please directly send me
an e-mail because once in a while they
reset the server and then it's not
working and only if somebody is telling
me then I will realize or if one of my
own students is using it but we will try
to keep this online and then people can
search for their favorite sequences so
back to to the topic so flour induction
in chili because that was the biological
project we worked on and well if you go
to the annual growth cycle of tulip and
I think that's known by a lot of people
if you're a full-grown chulip and in the
Netherlands it's planted in autumn and
late autumn already almost winter so end
of October beginning of November then a
boob is planted and the very first thing
that works and happens then is rooting
so you get rooting off the chilly boobs
and the most important is you need to
winter cold to release the tulip from
dormancy so this tulip it is rooting but
in form quite a long period you'll
hardly see anything happening from the
outside and only after sufficient winter
cold you get this very fast shooting
which then with this fast stem
elongation leads its spring to fall
blooming and exactly at that moment also
the new cycle is started because you get
the whole mother bulb is is consumed but
in that mother bulb you get daughter
bulbs formed and in the main daughter
bulb at that moment you get induction of
flowering so a lot of people think that
tulip is a fertilization responsive
plant because it needs winter cold
before you see the flower but actually
what winter cold is doing is breaking
dormancy so it's quite different from
fertilization and it's the warm
temperatures in summer that induce
flowering in the bud but in shortly
after after it's induced that but
becomes dormant and then you need again
you restart the cycle you need to winter
cold to break that dormancy so the first
part of my talk will focus on the effect
of its warm temperatures in spring
beginning of summer and of spring on the
induction of flowering
well as I said in the past quite some
research was done and already in the in
the 50s of the last century people have
been looking to to the switch of
flowering and how is the meristem level
inside the bulb should have a commerce
them how that is changing over time and
then you see very nicely in the
beginning it's it's a flat meristem if
it is a leaf primordium and the very
first thing that you can see when a bulb
starts to flower is that you get
swelling of the central meristem and
then shortly after you see that you see
the sibyl's
or which are called tipples in tulip
arising and very fast you see all the
different floral organs coming here you
see the stamens still in the middle and
then this is what's called the G stage
that's more or less the states that it
arrests them and becomes dormant so this
was already nicely described and that be
used as a reference to to study the
flowering process and then in the end
what you have is you F and you cut open
a poop and in the inside you have a
complete flower there but it's dormant
so what we did then and we thought well
how to do this because I was used to
Arab adopters that you can nicely grow
in growth chambers and and play around
with temperature and all kind of things
but growing to live in growth chambers
that is still it is possible and you can
do it you can grow it hydroponically but
we thought let's go to the natural
system but if you want them if we knew
that that ambient temperature that is
affecting flowering but if you plant
them outside you never know will it be
out here cold year and how to them get a
contrasting system where only the
temperature is different and then you
can see well in high temperature is
inducing flowering and a low temperature
not so we came into the idea to plant
tulips in crates so we put them in these
crates and then these crates were buried
in the soil and for the first part of
the whole growth season we left this
crates in the field until the moment
that they were nicely flowering and then
shortly after that so then the new cycle
should start and in the door tables that
are then throwing you get the induction
we placed these crates in the growth
chambers with either 9 degrees so
keeping the cold temperature that you
have around that time of the year or 18
degrees should get a fast induction of
flowering well normally in the
our induction process somewhere in
between the process the boobs gets
harvested and they are put in storage
and then switch to flowering depending
on the temperature in that spring is
happening slightly before that or
afterwards in storage so initially they
are stored around 20 degrees Celsius but
we said well if we are going to harvest
them in between that will have a lot of
effect because you damaged you you take
the roots off you dry the bulb so we
said let's let's keep them in this
creates until the moment of the bushido
to meristem switches so that's what we
what we looked at so the Bulls for
growing in the fields we transfer them
to the control to temperature conditions
we did this morphological
characterization and then based on that
morphological characterization we
decided to do an RNA seek so to see
which genes genome-wide gets activated
by the heat or repress by the heat and
not by the cold temperature and those
are then potentially involved in a
floral induction and for that we
isolated some candidates and then
preferably you would like to confirm
they're functioning in tulip but you'll
be difficult to transform so what we did
in the end we took the jeans from tulip
and we did a functional characterization
as flawlessly and Arab adopters so the
morphological characterization as I
mentioned already in the 50s they
figured out that this meristem that you
have to shoot up Commerce them initially
when this door bells are formed it's
flat you see only a leaf primordium
there so you have to basil plate and
yeah that's where the meristem is and
from the moment on that we place this
creates either a cold temperature a warm
temperature the very first five weeks we
didn't notice any difference between the
two temperatures the meristem remain
flat leaf primordia remained there it
grew a little bit but that was it so we
didn't saw in the very first five weeks
any sign of floral induction but a nice
thing came around week six week seven
then at the cold temperature you see
that if it keeps on staying very similar
so you have again I'm still that flat
meristem you have to leave primordius or
they'll be depending on on how you make
the preparation from which side you you
picture it but not what is happening
even after 10 weeks still its vegetative
but that's a warm temperature from week
6 you see the swelling pick 7 you can
see it very clearly and then in a very
short time 1 2 weeks
time you get a complete floral but there
so we are a nice system where we have
induction of flowering here at warm
temperature and no induction there and
that is the material that we used for
the RNA see but of course this is
visually and flowering is controlled the
whole activation of flowering must be
far before this moment so then we said
let's let's see also if we can get a
little bit more information what is
ongoing molecular lee and for that we
went to to our bead OPS's and anther
einem because there is one gene it's
called squamosa or a petal of one in
every Dobbs's that it's a black and
white gene making the difference between
the vegetative States any reproductive
states so it's completely off in the
vegetative States but as soon as one
starts flowering it's the flora Muslim
identity gene you see this team coming I
up and what you can see here very nicely
when we checked by qPCR the expression
of the gene in the warm temperature from
week six onwards and once you see it's
very steeply going up whereas in the
cold temperature and even week then it's
not shown here it remains of also
showing molecular lee yes there is
something ongoing from week six as I
indicated we were interested in in
floral induction so we decided not to
look too much here but we decided to
look especially from this moment on till
this moment because if you're interested
in the genes that trigger flowering you
should look what is happening before the
moment of switching home the floral
meristem identity game so here you see
an overview of that so what you see this
is a principal component analysis we
just selected zero weeks two weeks three
four five six up to seven and we didn't
Inara Masek on that in the AC just the
overall expression differences and now
as you can see very nice there are all
this green bluish colors they are from
the cold temperature you see that in the
cold temperature although it's seven
weeks period you hardly see anything
happening you also see that the initial
samples from the warm temperature are in
between here there are these yellow ones
over here but then in the warm if you go
already two-and-a-half weeks after the
start of this experiment when you don't
see anything on the activation you see
already that you get a big shift any
train
at home and especially around week three
for there are huge differences and for a
while it's a it's quite similar and then
week six seven you see again a huge
difference well these are actually all
the floor organized entity gains that
gets switched on so let me has an idea
on what is ongoing and you can also see
rate that molecular lee although
morphological you see something from
week six seven onwards molecular already
from the very first moment onwards you
see a very clear-cut effects on the
transcriptome well then of course the
question is what are that kind of genes
and for that we used so-called g
pathology analysis and we look to ovary
presentation because still it are
thousands of genes that are
differentially expressed and well the
problem is there is no chulip genome so
you have to somehow link a putative
function to these genes so based on the
annotation in Irbid offices and sequence
homology and annotation in rice V hooked
up a putative function to all these
genes and then we look for
over-represented terms and again what
you see it's week 2.5 up to seven and
it's always a comparison to time point
zero and these are the upregulated genes
and these are the down regulated genes
well there's a lot of information on it
but we will focus on on a very few cell
cycle that's an interesting one and you
see that's really high at week six
increased and that's the moment that you
see is swelling so a lot of this
swelling that you see is probably some
elongation but this enlargement of the
meristem is also a lot of cell division
probably so at the moment of switching
you get a boost of cell division and
that makes it you get them enlarged
meristem or not surprisingly vegetative
to reproductive phase transition genes
known to be involved in debt you see
them very nicely gradually going up
already two and a half weeks after the
induction in won't eat to come up and a
peak at six weeks and then they go down
so this is not so surprising me but I
want to warn you you are interested in
flowering and you think every team that
is going up has to do something with
flowering or every game that is going
down but that is of course not the case
you always you go back and think what is
more happening to these tulips because
at the same moment other things are
happening and mmm I will say that one
later and what we notice is there are a
lot of genes the
see process seed maturation response to
abscisic acid and initially thought hey
a chilly boob is not a seed but if you
think it's a reproductive structure that
is shortly after drying and what we
noticed is that the program that is
activated together
it's Tula bit over winters and it's
similar as the program that is activated
in seeds to get a dormant seed and the
seed can overwinter and germinate next
spring so a lot of genes that are in
seed maturation response have suggested
in dormancy you find them nicely getting
up regulated probably having nothing to
do with the induction of flowering but
by preparing the boob for this dormant
period and overwinter well one thing
that I forgot that was the RNA splicing
those who were there on Friday heard for
me that temperature especially this
ambient temperatures which is inducing
flowering they act a lot at the splicing
level and I was very surprised and also
happy to see that also here RNA splicing
is one of the major components but we
didn't dive into it because there's not
a good annotated transcriptome and
genome and then it's very difficult to
get hand on all these different isoforms
that are there but it seems that also in
tulip may be part of this regulation of
floral induction is happening at the
splicing and level for a link to all the
seed terms that are activated you see
that at the same own because what this
bill does it's preparing for dormancy
you see that all in the downregulated
it's mainly metabolic processes that
gets down regulators so you see very
nicely there at the same moment that
flowering is induced the whole bulb is
preparing for a long silent period and
low metabolic activity oh yeah sorry
that I didn't mention it all this is
isolated from from the shoot apical
meristem yeah so it's only shoot up
Commerce some material
well then focus on some jeans again it's
based on our bid opposite fifty
annotations but a well-known repressor
of flowering in our bid offices is
called terminal flower it's in the same
family as FTD Floridian but it's an you
can see it as an anti Floridian and what
we very nicely seed is that that gene
soon as you place tulips in the warmth
its expression is going down whereas in
the cold very gradually it goes down but
it takes about six seven eight weeks
longer before it's completely down so
suggesting that the functionality of
this Dean
it's very conserved and a terminal
flower is an active repressor of
flowering in in tulips and something
similar you see for a sock one like gene
that's remarkable because sock one is
known as an activator of flowering and
this one like gene seems also to be a
repressor because in the warmth it's
going down and in the heat it's going up
and this is also shown directly how
difficult it is to working with another
species because we also found a sock
like gene that access soap on in Irbid
opposite that is going in the heat it's
going up so this sock is probably an
activator in this sock based on
expression you would expect it's a
repressor of flowering so now at this
moment we are following up these two
copies of sock one to figure out exactly
what they are doing and if they maybe
counteract each other and that the
balance between these two copies is
determining the moment of flowering well
that's that's so nice if you see that
then and then you can think well we
identified the genes but if you want in
the end you want the final confirmation
because maybe you can recall that how we
did this experiment we were planting
this bouffes in in crates we took them
up and put them at continuous call for
continuous warm temperature we were also
not harvesting them we left them in the
crates till the moment of flowering
that's quite different from how it
normally goes in the field so we said
well maybe we should redo this
experiment and that we did two years
later but then leave the bulbs in the
ground in the field as normal dig them
up store them in a normal storage and
then see what some going in
that's what we did so we repeated the
experiment and then we also decided to
include different cultivars that have
quite different moment of blooming and
spring so strong gold for example a very
late Flower yellow flight even later
there's purple prince is a very early
variety so here you see this is an April
4th month we always turned it around in
the middle and somehow in comparison to
how you are doing that so it's all in
April and you see very nicely that there
is quite a big difference sometimes even
three weeks before you see blooming but
it's good to realize is that what we are
looking at is its flower induction and
that is something different from
blooming because the moment of blooming
does not only depend on the moment that
a flowering is in use but it also
depends on how much dormancy destitute
of have and there came one interesting
thing because strong gold here it's a
very late cultivar and that would mean
that jeans like terminal flower would be
repressed later but if you look to the
switch strong gold is earlier so yellow
means reproductive and green vegetative
if you compare purple prince which is
much earlier blooming in spring to
strong gold which is a very late one you
see that strong gold then you look to
the switch of the meristem it's the
opposite so strong goal is a very heat
is very efficiently switching the
meristem to flowering whereas in purple
Prince it's much later so that's showing
that the difference in flowering time in
the spring is not determined by the
difference in the moment of switching
but mainly by how how much dormancy does
a particular tulip cultivar have it also
means that they didn't use in the end
this flowering time this blooming time
to assert for the association between it
we looked again to the meristems of this
material and The Associated expression
of the genes with this switch and then
what you can see very nicely this
terminal flower gene that that you
compare strong gold with purple prince
you see that in strong gold which is
about 2 to 3 weeks earlier making a
switch also terminal flower is going
about three to two weeks earlier down so
there's a very nice correlation between
the expression of genes like terminal
flower with
the moment they make the switch of the
meristem but not less the moment they
are blooming the next year because that
is linked to the dormancy cycle Oh
there are also correlations at least
it's also in the natural situation we
showed that the same genes and I showed
you only terminal flower but the same
was the case for sort squamosa
all these genes have been identified so
it was very robust but I add these teens
really repressors of flowering so to
study that a little bit more what we did
is we took the tulip terminal flower
gene and we introduced it into our bird
OPS's and then scored for flowering time
and then yes indeed when you overexpress
that you live terminal flower gene Arab
adoption indeed you get a much later
flowering also confirming that this
protein as a flowering repressing
capacity well bill already remind me
that I should say something on the
tissue that I isolated at the meristems
and maybe one things coming up with you
if you will know a little bit on
flowering time research where is flora
June because I didn't talk about
Floridian yes and you would expect that
in the heat flow region goes up and that
is then triggering flowering and I
didn't talk about Florida just you too
baby
but have Floridian well it has but a you
have to realize where a Floridian in
most cases is expressed that is for
example in Irbid offices it's not
expressed at all in the shoot apical
meristem it's expressed in the leaves
and moving from there a signal to the
shoot apical meristem so we sampled only
shoot apical meristem material and that
was maybe the reason that we didn't
found the true flora giin homolog from
children so to go back into our database
because we said there must be a
Floridian so we went back to our
database and we looked in there can we
find f team members that are maybe
having this foraging function and we
found so there is as I indicated
terminal flower also belongs to them to
the Floridian
clade to the ft year family it's a
repressor of flowering and it's very
nicely groups together with the Arab
lobsters terminal flower the terminal
flower from barley from from rye so you
see it's very conserved the functioning
of this family from die cuts to monocots
you see that the repressors are in the
same subclade and then we also found two
FC lights every like one
at two st1 and st2 which are in the same
sub plate as the Arab adopters ft and
twin sister of F T so activate is a
flower ring and they suggest that these
are them the true Floridians of tulip
there's also a very interesting one here
TGIF t3 because it's in this clade and
if you know the abbreviations you will
maybe see that a seed it's onion
actually in this subclade there are only
bulbous plant species making it very
interesting it seems to be an F T clade
that is bubu specific and at the moment
we are following that up what is in the
function of these and our family members
so 2ft like deans and well again MMB fft
free and it's a big question what that
is one is doing because it's blue blue
specific so there is no Arab adopts auto
log of that one so we cannot learn
anything there from Irbid OPS's but
again what we did is well to prove that
they are may be involved that we first
look to the expression and then you see
that FD one very nicely comes up around
may in leaves stem and also in the
flower ft2 which is to supposed
flowering together with ft-1 inducing
one the floridian also around April May
but also FD free which is in that
strange boobs specific blade has a very
similar expression pattern coming up
mainly leaves and stem around April and
May so looking to this expression we
could not distinguish its f t1 t2 or
maybe this boob is specific ft 3 the
real flaw region so what we did there is
again we went to arabi Dobson and I know
that doing this had for all of the
studies it's not ideal but that was the
best we could do so we ectopic Lee
expressed these genes in Arabic ops and
we hoped that one of them would give
floral induction well the funny thing
was when we topically expressed FD one
which is in the same clade as the
arbiter of such floridian we got a
slight delay of flowering it's not much
but it's significant difference we get a
late flowering plant
ft2 which is in the same clade that
seems to be the real origin because or
you can see here after producing only a
very few leaves you get flowering so FC
2 seems to be the real Floridian of
tulip and after the free that is the one
the boob of specific one also that there
is a significant effect it makes the
I read of such flowering slightly later
but it can be that there is completely
different from the function in tulip
because this type of gene is not present
in marabou tops as normally so to
conclude this part based on what we have
seen now is that high temperature is
definitely the trigger for floral
induction in in tulip what it does
probably in the Leafs it activates
already early in April so very at the
moment that the mother plant is still
flowering it activates genes like f t2
so the real flaw region which and give a
positive boost to the meristem and
slightly later but far before you see
flowering it represses genes like T G
terminal flower one and C G shot one as
a consequence of this repressing this
repressing factor ohm for Merstham
identity genes is going down you see
also that the shock one like gene is
activated at the positive one and this
then gives the switch and you get a
floral meristem produced around July
laid you in the new daughter bulb and
you get activation very shortly after of
all the floor organ identity genes so
this is our current working model and
yeah what we hope to do is in the new
projects get more insight in what are
these different ft is doing and can be
then somehow for at least for the
breeding industry get a way to get
around this signaling and boost
flowering already very fast in tulip so
that they can much more efficiently
cross juleps and back cross tulips and
not beat 20-30 generation 20-30 years to
get new traits bred into Julie so the
second topic dormancy control in in
tulip and well that's all about this
part the regulation of dormancy so I
said already it's actually tulip is not
a generalization responsive plant it
needs warm temperatures to induce
flowering as you've just seen but after
that at the same moment what eat is also
in Dulce is a dormancy program and the
same as you have in seed dormancy and
you need a winter coat to reduce the
dormancy and to get full blooming in
spring and fast stem elongation as you
see nice in this example here you see
strong gold
this is from one of these flower shows
where they showed this very nice long
elongated strong go its obtain
sufficient cold but if you don't have
strong golf coats you get something like
this actually it was done at at the
house of the grandmother of the PhD she
she kept this plant for us always a
night atmosphere all people have a warm
house or they were continuously above 20
degrees and then you see that you get
some flowers but they are hardly along
gating and the flowers also stay closed
they not open up showing that you really
need cold and besides strong bulb we did
a lot of other cultivars and some
cultivars sometimes even completely
degenerate if you don't give them cold
the whole bulb disappears or the floral
but completely disappears so cold is
definitely needed as a next step in the
life cycle so once more we were
interested in what is occurring during
the winter period and so what we did if
you did again a detailed morphological
analysis in times we look to the growth
and the length of the floor meristem and
the stem inside we did a physiological
analysis we were measuring carbohydrates
on the dynamics grow so primary
metabolites and we did again a
transcriptional analysis to figure out
what is now exactly ongoing inside such
a bulb at the moment it gets released
from from dormancy by cold or first
something on the growth one thing that
we if we realize because what is
dormancy you know there's always a lot
of discussion ongoing what is now real
I've tissues really in rest or not in
maybe they are visibly in rest that may
be molecularly a lot of things are
ongoing so we were really surprised or
really curious what is now happening
happening in in a chilly pool and one
thing what we notice is if that we every
measure the complete shoot that is
inside the chilly bulb here from strong
gold and dynasty from really from the
basal plate till the tip and you look
over time so this is minus 10 that means
10 weeks before planting week 0 is the
moment of counting and then you see the
initial winter months and then in the
spring or definitely you can see that at
a certain moment of of stretching that
is after the dormancy is gone but if you
look to the chute as a whole there is
not
any moment that it's completely not
growing so you could say there is no
dormancy at all because there is maybe
growth retardation but the shoot as a
whole keeps on growing well that's the
suit as a whole but they also did we
measured only the floral but part and
then there's a very nice thing which you
can see above in Dynasty and strong gold
in Dynasty is a little bit shorter than
in strong gold there is a period where
there is no significant growth of the
bud and then you can sing well what does
that matter but if what it shows is that
maybe you can compare a chilled in this
respect to for example trees which have
but dormancy so it's not the complete
structure that is dormant the stem keeps
on along gating a little bit but it's
especially the floral but that for
periods sometimes of the case of strong
gold for for about two months it's
completely not growing once more this is
growth that does not mean that's
molecularly nothing is happening but at
least in growth you can say well there
is but dormancy so the but is completely
not not elongated oh why is that well
it's very well known that the tulip
bulbs like also seeds they have also
they are a storage organ and there is a
lot of stars in a newly-built but it's
not available sugar of course for growth
it needs to be degraded and broken down
into soluble sugars before the pound can
grow so what we did is we measured here
the expression of alpha amylase that's
the enzyme that is breaking down starch
and then as you can very nicely see that
you compare Dynasty we've strong gold
that soon this is the cold period and
big 0 planting that as soon you plant
them directly in Dynasty alpha-amylase
goes up it stays up quite long and then
it's really fast going up and then it
drops whereas it's strong gold you see
that it takes a little bit longer to get
up but then it keeps on going and this
reflects very nicely also the behavior
because I just showed you that although
strong gold is a fast switcher it's a
late flowering one so that's also what
you see it takes strong gold longer to
activate alpha amylase but then if it's
up and that's why it's maybe also such a
strong cultivar it very efficiently
keeps on expressing all families and
probably really efficiently breaking
down all the starch whereas dynasty is
faster and that's maybe also why it's
blooming for
during spring but it's a little bit less
efficient in taking all the starch down
well then we thought about but that's
all formulas I call it here activity but
its expression it's the expression
reflecting the enzyme activity because
there are many enzymes that are not
regulated at the expression level so we
compared alpha amylase activity which is
the expression with the amounts of
glucose fructose and sucrose and then
you can very nicely see that there is a
nice correlation between the expression
level of alpha amylase and the amounts
of so both sucrose available in the
immature lip and if you compare them
that to the growth of the floral stem
and the floral butt and the leaves you
see that there is a perfect correlation
between the amount of glucose that you
can measure in the bulbs and the growth
so there is a one-to-one relationship
between the amount of available soluble
sugars and the growth capacity of the
tissue
well then about transcripts and what we
did is we did again a global gene
expression a response during the winter
period and what we did there is we
compared in this graph the number of
transcripts that are significantly
altered in comparison to four weeks
prior to planting so that was our first
time point so we started sampling
already during the storage and then
within the storage so time point zero is
just before planting so it's still
storage so the booths are not moved or
whatever are planted that's time point
zero and then this is two weeks after
planting ten weeks after planting when
you really see this boost of growth and
twelve weeks after planting well then if
you looked at in the scales these are
transcripts that are differential but
going up in comparison to four weeks in
the storage or four weeks before
planting and these are transcripts going
down but anyways you can see that you
see gradually more activity in the book
when you go from week zero two weeks M
very nicely showing this dormancy
response that and the glucose and the
Grove so with the activity also in inner
scales the activity of the genes is
going up and especially at the moment
the dormancy is fully released you have
a lot of activity also a lot of these
it's down regulated so a complete new
transcript ik transcriptional program is
coming up
when you're looking to the floral but we
were quite surprised because I just told
you the floral but it's not doing a lot
during the period it's really kind of
but dormancy
that you also see back in when you
compare week two six eight twelve you
see that transcriptionally not a lot is
happening in the bud but something that
we completely didn't expect is that
during the last weeks in a storage so
four - four to zero the floral but is
the most active transcriptionally so we
think that that but is dormant and you
don't see any growth happening but
transcriptionally somehow this but knows
that winter will come and is preparing
already itself for the next generation
and I think that's very good to keep in
mind there's a big difference between
what you see on the outside and what is
internal happening it probably also
means that this is maybe developmentally
regulated because nothing is changing
it's just in storage at the same
temperature but still you see a lot of
transcriptionally ongoing so probably
it's the age of the bulb or whatever
that is measuring that and already
telling well you have to prepare because
a new season a new period will will
arrive well we are still busy with going
in depth in it but here you see a gene
ontology analysis in this case of the
floral but comparing week - four and
twelve that is the moment at the buds
game gets active and then you can very
nicely see that things that's also for a
long time it was silent but starts
metabolic process growth cell
differentiation floral world for the
development of the florals transport is
activated so you can very nicely see
when you compare storage when it's very
dormant in growth and finally after the
dormancy period you see all this
processes that you expect coming up
because of course more interesting is
what is happening during those first
stages and we are still digging further
into that at this moment this is in the
Leafs and there is an again another
interesting aspects because you compare
week zero two weeks while if it's just
at the moment they become they release a
dormancy of course in the leaf you see
things like response to carbohydrate
stimulus response to temperature
stimulus this is what you expect but one
thing that we were not expecting because
as soon as a leaf comes above ground it
needs to start for
synthesizing and they can think at least
that was my naive way of thinking maybe
it's the light that is activating the
photosynthesis apparatus but a very
funny thing was that we see that the
genes involved in photosynthesis in
light reaction are already activated
before the leaf comes above the ground
so at week 12 the boob is still on the
ground so it hasn't seen any light the
chute is also wide and then already you
see that the whole photosynthetic
apparatus is set up meaning that that is
not triggered by the environment
probably but again that that is a
developmentally triggered trait so
somehow this know soon I will come above
the ground and it's better that I
already prepare for that and set up my
photosynthesis system oh then about the
metabolomics
analysis also that we did we did it for
the scales floral but they also did it
for the stem but I only show here the
PGA's of the scale in the floral but and
this is the PCA plot but you can nicely
see is you see a clear-cut switz where
you go from 0 to 4 not that much is
happening in the scale but then you get
a clear cuts which when you go to the
later time points and especially at the
moment the dormancy is released so
around week 14 12 14 you see again that
there is a big change when you go
compared to time from 0 flow but you see
initially that they are a little bit
mixed up here and if to realize its
principle component and you see that the
raw zero is here and here these are the
replicates so not that much is happening
and only during the last time point you
see metabolically a lot is is ongoing in
AC just some examples Reutimann
asparagine proline formula means I lost
menos we are currently in the status of
looking more into that what is now
exactly I'm going at a metabolite
regulation and what is even more
important we try to link that to what is
happening at a transcriptome level
because we're from the same time points
also the transcriptomic data from the
different tissue so at the moment I'm a
statistician and a bioinformatician are
busy to integrate these two datasets so
unfortunately I cannot say more about
that at this moment because simply we
haven't done all the analysis yet so to
summarize this part glucose levels are
actually perfectly correlated with
growth capacity of the different organs
in which you look and very
nice way of measuring how far the tulip
is in its dormancy cycle and another
remarkable thing was that Leafs are
preparing for photosynthesis to become
the new energy source of carbohydrates
already before the plant emerges
above-ground so this seems to be
developmentally regulated and what was
also interesting to see is that although
tissue seems to be dormant at the
transcriptional level we found it
surprised that the floral but during the
last period of storage is very very
active in already preparing for for the
next step so far about flowering and
yeah so I will show a few things on
vegetative reproduction and probably I
see that a lot to go over time it cannot
say Oh everything this part is also
short but I would like to show you
something on because at the moment that
the tulip is in using flowering it is
also going into vegetative reproduction
daughter built formation and there the
question is at least for growers what is
the reason that tulips make actually so
little daughter bulbs in general there
are free daughter books that have
decides to give again a flowering bulb
in the next generation and also if you
look to these daughter bulbs are free
that have a normal size but they're also
these small ones that don't grow out at
all and why is that not equally
distributed well for that you first have
to look again in how is this developing
him if you look very early in the but in
the mother bird October at the moment
you plant it you see that these are the
positions in the scale stay but the age
but most outer one and you see that
actually the one this is the most close
to the shoot apical meristem that is the
smallest and one which is outside is the
biggest so it more or less resembles the
apical dominance what you normally see
it but axillary but that is the the most
close to the central but that is the
most dormant but if you look in over
time you see that a bud which is the
smallest in the beginning is directly
catching of growth and becoming the
biggest ones
whereas the C and the D but which are
quite big already at the mo and
beginning they stay small and they stay
small until the end so they stay a kind
of dormant except for the age but also
one that is also growing out quite
efficiently so you see instead of one
gradient that you have here which you
could explain maybe by apical dominance
you have two
in the final outgrowth of daughter bulbs
a one very simple reason reasoning could
be that's a matter of sink source and a
resources because they but that is close
to the central stem where you have the
mother build flowering so a lot of
photosynthesis ongoing and also the age
about gifts of Massoud above the ground
which can also produce so you have two
positions where you have resources so we
said well maybe it's sink source and to
study that we decided to look to the a
but and a D but so we cut it from the
bulbs in December and what we did is we
took those buds and we were placing them
in vitro to see if we then apply sucrose
is it sinks or sink and then the D D but
grow as fast as the a but well one thing
that we notice is that if we don't give
them any sucrose all of them of course
there is respiration they reduce they
reduce in their dry weight and the D but
is even that is that small it's even
dying so that's it cannot sustain that
but if you put them on six percent
sucrose
our idea what stable all grow with the
same capacity because then there are
sufficient resources but a bud is nicely
growing but still the D but it stays
alive but it's not growing at all so
definitely it's not only a matter of
seeing source that is determining which
bodies are growing there must be
something else oh the only thought maybe
it's the connection with the vasculature
and that D but it's just isolated from
the rest and not nicely connected to the
source but that may be sustaining of the
first lecture in the a but in a C but
and in the D but so the pinkish color is
too first lecture and of course there is
a bigger vessel ature in this big a but
and in the smaller C and E but but also
the smaller C and D but this is quite
nice faster connection so it seems not
to be that they are isolated from the
rest of the plant well then what is then
the cause of this is blocking then again
I'm not a bird of such person and I
thought what can it be and then a
thought of maybe I should look what is
the notice on out Grove axillary immerse
them in other species like Araby table
system
it's good to realize that a Julie boob
is actually a compact compacted plant
underground
clowns so the basal plate is the same as
the stem the scales are kind of modified
leaves also transcriptomic Li they look
like petals of leaves and then the
daughter bullshit's grow here inside are
actually actually meristems
and we know very well what are the genes
repressing actually meristem outgrowth
from species like maize and teosinte and
also RB Dobbs's you have the gene
branched one which is a very conserved
repressor of actually immerse them out
growth so that made us think well maybe
there is also a truly branched one that
is repressing these meristems from
outgrowth so we looked in that so we had
this buts nine days after culture day
but growing very well on six percent
sucrose the D but not and what we did is
we checked the expression we isolated
based on our database brainstorm from
Chile and we see very nicely that in the
D but there is a high expression of
branched one whereas an a but it's not
over time it's going down but it never
reaches the low level that a bird has so
it seems that branch one is somehow
repressing outgrowth of this inner but
I'll forget it some more confirmation of
that we decided to look in so-called
spring pate tulips that are tulips there
where in contrast to normal tulips where
the outgrowth of axillary buds is more
or less similar so somehow this tulips
lose that capacity of differentiating an
outgrowth all the Buffs grow out with
the same speed and if brains one is a
repressor it should mean that there is
no branch one repression in all these
buts and this is triggered for example
by ethylene or particular temperature
treatments you can trigger this spring
pate behavior we look to brain salon
expression and what you see very nicely
in the normal situation it's you get a
curve you compare ABCD age spots which
is opposite to the growth curve but in
the spring Pattaya you see there's maybe
a little bit more expression in C and B
but you see very nice that actually
branch one is almost completely off
explaining why then all the bulbs can
grow out with an equal speed so too
include this part daughter bill velcro
is not solely a matter of seeing source
relationships and carbon distribution
there's a molecular parfait acting on
top of that and Dean's like Prince Juan
they seem to be key players in dormancy
control and low temperatures inside the
greens I didn't show that but we have
done experiments on that they can
repress prints one expression and in
that way give if outgrowth of axillary
buds so a few less slides on because
this is outgrowth of meristems if I'm
allowed to give also the initiation of
meristems and we are also interested in
that and then Lily comes in because
chillip besides that it is that you have
these books that are not out growing
that are dormant it also produces only a
very few accelerate meristems and also
when you bring it in culture it's very
difficult to get new axillary muslims
initiating it to get regeneration in
contrast Lily when you take a lily scale
and you make a cutting of that and you
put it just in a moisture condition you
don't have that any hormone or whatever
in a very short period you get all kind
of small nice daughter boobs on the edx
your side of the build scale so we were
wondering what is happening there and
it's Lily there may be a nice model to
study the initiation of regeneration in
both species and they see that in only
10 days so this is one of those skill
explains that we keep it I'm just on the
way to filter paper and ready within ten
days you see first swelling of the axial
bottom side where the one was and
shortly after you see a very nice
meristem appearing and then when you
followed it up in time in in a relative
short time after that appearing of that
meristem you see that an oil very nice
meristem with two scales is forming and
you get this nice small boob that's
formed so a very nice experimental
system to study initiation of meristems
in completely differentiated material
because the scale is a modified leaf
completely differentiated tissue so a
very first thing that we asked is how
can this very differentiated cells and
you see a cross section of that regions
on the axial side so directly after the
cut and here the nuclei are stained by
by dap you see a lot of black
all start so these are huge cells with a
lot of starts in that and within ten
days they can somehow activate em and
reprogram and if cell division so we
looked with brdu a cell cycle marker
which is marking the DNA synthesis what
is happening an agency very nice already
one day after the cut you see first
nuclei lighting up and already three
days after the cut they look like it's a
Christmas tree or a star you see that
there are many cells here reprogramming
and able to start dividing as you can
also nicely see from this cross-section
this is the abaxial side this is the ED
axial side on the abaxial side you see
very few small cells but here on the add
actual side you see a lot of cells that
lose the starch which you see here in
these big cells small cells that are
asymmetric division under the epidermal
cell the epidermal cell itself at a
certain moment what it does it breaks
and from below you get a meristem formed
so very fast in 10 days times it is able
to reprogram and give this kind of bulb
which is breaking through the meristem
and get an organized meristem formed
well a very simple question we had them
from urban offices is known that this
kind of meristems they originated not
from every cell but are often so-called
parry cycle cells there are the cells
close to the to the vascular bundle that
can regenerate and not every cell has
this capacity so we were also asking it
comes from the inside is it may be also
very cyclic cells Lily so we did a very
simple experiment where we cut
excellence because it's it's a monocot
so the first structure is nicely linear
organized so we took excellence without
facility and excellence which first
mature and we check is the difference in
regeneration capacity or apparently it's
not
you see regeneration in both cases so it
seems not to depend on the vasculature
and also when you look in time so the
different regeneration stages you see
that both type of excellence they
regenerate with the same speed so then
of course to do the question comes what
is them triggering this de novo build
with regeneration in tulips and can it's
no less than B transfer to recall stand
drop crops such as
tulip so I will not go in detail in that
what we did is
we did an RNA seek and we took a good in
a bad regenerating Lily and we also made
excellence from the bottom side of the
scale and the top side secure because
the more ethical path is doing less good
in regeneration and a basal part so we
had four different situations which you
could compare with each other and hey is
he more or less out of this happening so
this is in Bayes the very fast
regenerating one already at six seven
days we see this but coming and then you
see the the most poor one so the top of
the poor regenerating one we see them
only after 18 days and much less in
number so we had a very nice
differential system to do RNA seek on
well that's what we did and here you see
just a plot of expression so we did a so
called self organizing map approach and
then you can very see that there are
already after one day of culture a lot
of genes starting to especially in the
good regenerating one to to be activated
and they are response to oxidative
stress response to warming and very
shortly after you see already genes
immerse them gains and atomic structure
development post embryonic development
activated and one example of that is STM
that's the gene in Irbid offices which
is marking the shoot apical meristem and
you see very nicely in the good basil
it's coming up at one day you see it
already and already after three five
days its speaking and as much from level
whereas in the poor regenerating one you
see it's coming up also a little bit but
then compare it to the good basil it's
it's coming up a little bit but then it
stays there and not able to really boost
this regeneration so we also look to
cell cycle genes and I cannot go into
detail more now but just idea that there
is a kind of booming response that's
also well known probably a reactive
oxygen species they take a
differentiation and already within one
day that we've also seen from a cell
cycle marker you get cycling's activated
and genes like STM that organized the
meristem activated leading to cell
division and leading already ten days
later to an organized meristem still
it's the question what is it a material
activating signal and what we realize is
that there are although the epidermis
seems
to be involved are a few epidermal genes
very nicely popping up really early in
the in the RNA seek so that triggered us
to do an experiment like this so
normally you always see them only on the
EDX your side not only a better side and
we said what will happen if you remove
either the EDX your side or DM exercise
so if you remove the EDX your side the
funny thing is that you get here on the
corners you get regeneration so the
regeneration on the EDX your side is
completely gone if you remove the
abaxial side nothing is that mean that
good regeneration if you remove both you
get no reinjure regeneration at all so
there seems to be a kind of trigger from
the epidermis to the underground layers
telling you have to start regenerating
and we are currently trying to identify
what is this triggering signal with that
I will stop and just mention I want to
mention the two people who did actually
all this work that is Melissa she
finished her PhD thesis you heard all
the flowering time research and we have
Natalia who did all this propagation
work in Lille anime
xiulet and at this moment we have a new
project ongoing with steam with Lori and
again okay
half a bay and there we study especially
lifecycle shortening and we do that
together with Utrecht University student
and it's partly supported by doing
orange the fundamental breeding company
and with that I'd like to end by also
mentioning all the all the other people
who were involved so this was all done
within the plant physiology Department
and here you see the plant physiology
people where I was one day in a week but
Melissa Anatole were continuous video
actually Novotny on seed lab group
Harbin - an area worth savoring are the
BIOS mutations we did all the great work
on this de novo RNA seek assembly role
on them in your room from our car
metabolomics people so they did this
metabolomic research fulness and alex on
sil vout and all atoms from the palm
breeding department they helped us out
in growing the tulips because we i had
no experience at all with till there was
a narrow bit officers person and finally
michelle Sakai with her we did work on
the ft family thanks for your attention
sorry for the laser
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu